THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> Sean: SARA CARTER,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER.
HERE WITH REACTION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI.
MR. MAYOR, I KNOW THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN SAYING AND YOU'VE BEEN
SAYING YOU AREN'T GOING TO
TESTIFY IN FRONT OF ANY
COMMITTEE UNLESS THERE IS A VOTE
IN CONGRESS WHETHER OR NOT THEY
SHOULD REMOVE HIM.
DOESN'T IT ALSO HAVE TO INCLUDE
THE FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS ISSUES
THAT NEWT GINGRICH GAVE THE
DEMOCRATS IN '98?
>> IT'S ALL IN HERE, SEAN.
A GREAT LETTER BY PAT CIPOLLONE
HE.
SIX VIOLATIONS OF THE PRESIDENTS
CIVIL RIGHTS, MY CIVIL RIGHTS,
TEN GENERAL BARR IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS.
I NEVER WANTED IN MY LIFE WANT
TO APPEAR IN A SALEM WITCH TRIAL
WHICH WOULD BE FAIRER THAN THIS,
IT'S A PROCESS WITHOUT ANY DUE
PROCESS AND THE FACT IT'S BEING
ENABLED BY A COMPLETELY CORRUPT
PRESS CORPS.
I DON'T KNOW.
DO YOU THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR ON THE PRESS THAT A MEMBER
OF THE UKRAINE PARLIAMENT HELD A
PRESS MEETING TODAY -- YOU WILL
NOT HEAR IT ON THE NEWS, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN.
YOU CENSOR IT.
YOU'LL ONLY HEAR THE NEWS THAT
DEMS WANT YOU TO HEAR.
DESCRIBE THE MECHANISM GETTING
MONEY BY BIDEN SENIOR.
THIS IS A TRANSFER OF FUNDS AS
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE BY
JOE BIDEN THROUGH A LOBBYING
COMPANY.
THE FUNDS AND AMOUNT OF $900,000
WHICH ANSWERED TO THE U.S. BASED
COMPANY ROSEMONT SENECA WHICH
ACCORDING TO OPEN SOURCES IS
AFFILIATED WITH BIDEN.
THE PAYMENT WAS FOR CONSULTATIVE
SERVICES AND GOES ON TO DESCRIBE
ANOTHER $16.5 MILLION PAYMENT
APPARENTLY LAUNDERED PAYMENT
INVOLVING BOTH DEVON ARCHER AND
HUNTER, USING POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC LEVERS OF POWER,
INFLUENCING UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES, AND MANIPULATING
THE ISSUE OF PROVIDING FINANCIAL
AID, JOE BIDEN ACTIVELY ASSISTED
ENCLOSING CRIMINAL CASES.
THIS IS BASED ON A STATEMENT
TODAY BY A PARLIAMENT MEMBER IN
THE UKRAINE, A VERY SENIOR ONE.
SAYING THAT JOE BIDEN ACTIVELY
ASSISTED CLOSING CRIMINAL CASES
INTO THE ACTIVITY OF FORMER
UKRAINIAN ECOLOGY MINISTER WHO
IS THE FOUNDER AND OWNER OF
BURISMA GROUP.
HE'S A MAJOR OLIGARCH, STALL
$5 BILLION FROM HIS PEOPLE.
HE VERY SUSPICIOUSLY WAS ALLOWED
TO COME BACK.
HIS CASE GOT DISMISSED WHEN THEY
DISMISS HUNTER BIDEN'S CASE BUT
HE'S THE GUY WHO PAID THE
16.5 MILLION AND THE 900,000 TO
THE BIDENS -- WELL IT WASN'T
16.5, IT WAS MORE 5 MILLION.
THIS GUY IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
CRIMINALS OF THE UKRAINE AND
HE'S NOW WALKING AROUND FREE
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN GOT THE CASE
DISMISSED.
THIS GENTLEMAN HAS SAID THAT
THIS INFORMATION SHOULD BE
TURNED OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR THEIR OWN PURPOSES
THEY SHOULD INVESTIGATE IT AND
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU WHY, SEAN.
THEY SUSPECT THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UKRAINE RECEIVED A VERY
MAJOR BRIBE IN ORDER TO TANK
THIS CASE.
I'M NOT SAYING BIDEN WAS
INVOLVED IN THE BRIDE BUT IT'S
THE ONLY THING HE WASN'T
INVOLVED IN.
THIS CASE STINGS, THEY CAN RUN
AWAY FROM IT ALL THEY WANT.
SEAN, I WANT TO KEEP YOUR EYE
NOT JUST ON CHINA, I WANT YOU TO
KEEP YOUR EYE ON ROMANIA.
JUST WATCH ROMANIA.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS --
>> YOU WON'T READ IT IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"WASHINGTON POST," BUT JUST
WATCH ROMANIA.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, I HAVE IN
MY POSSESSION AN EMAIL FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
>> YES!
THEY'VE GOT EVIDENCE.
I HAVE IT TOO.
>> Sean: THEY PUT ME ON A
PROGRAM AND I SPOKE TO 68
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISTS, THEY
DATED THIS MAY 302016.
>> IT'S MORE COLLUSION!
REMEMBER TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION?
THIS IS CALLED ILLEGAL
COLLUSION.
BY THE WAY, IT'S BY THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
ADMITTED, BECAUSE WE CAUGHT THIS
BY AN OPERATIVE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE,
ONE OF THE OFFICES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
TALKING ABOUT PUTTING, OH,
PUTTING FOREIGNERS, UKRAINIANS
IN CONTACT WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"!
A GENTLEMAN BY THE WAY OF
IZIKOFF.
BY THE WAY, ISN'T THAT WHAT
DONALD JR. DIDN'T DO?
>> Sean: "YOU NEED TO BE AWARE
OF, SOMETHING I'M WORKING OF
THAT YOU'LL BE AWARE OF.
SINCE I STARTED DIGGING INTO MAN
AFFORD, THESE MEN MESSAGES HAVE
BEEN A DAILY OCCURRENCE RATE
SPEAKING ABOUT MAN AFFORD, AND I
INVITED MICHAEL ISIKOFF WHO I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
HAVE YOU CONFIRMED THIS WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMUNITY?
>> I CONFERRED A COUPLE OF
THINGS IN THE FILE BY UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR HANDED OVER TO ME
LAST JANUARY AND I'VE BEEN
KEEPING SO I CAN REBUFF SO WHEN
THE SWAMP MEDIA COMES AFTER ME
AND ATTACKED MY LAW FIRM, LAW
OFFICE, GOES INTO MY DIVORCE
CASE WHICH THEY ARE DOING RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT I WANT TO TELL THEM IS
EVERY TIME YOU GO AFTER ME
ANOTHER PIECE OF EVIDENCE IS
GOING TO COME OUT WHEN YOU GIVE
ME A PLATFORM TO GAPE IT OUT AND
I'VE GOT MANY MORE OF THE SPIRIT
IS WHAT THEY CALL, PEOPLE,
EVIDENCE.
NOT LIES.
PLENTY OF EVIDENCE THAT BIDEN,
HIS SON, HIS BROTHER HAD A
30-YEAR LONG SCAM TO MAKE MONEY,
MILLIONS, SELLING HIS PUBLIC
OFFICE.
SENATOR FIRST, VICE PRESIDENT
SECOND.
UKRAINE IS THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
I TOLD YOU, TOLD YOU ABOUT
ROMANIA, AND WE GO BACK TO ALL
THE STEALING HE DID WHEN HE WENT
BACK TO THE SENATE.
THIS IS A LONG-TERM BIDEN
INCORPORATED.
>> Sean: THIS SOUNDS LIKE A
RICO INVESTIGATION BACK IN YOUR
OLD DAYS.
>> I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
RICO CASE.